tell us all about the day hi good
afternoon Samuel um well I've been with
Samuel for the whole day we've looked at
six properties throughout the Walsall
area really good cracking range of
properties all very good got down to two
properties that we were really sort of
interested in we put an offer in on one
that was originally hundred twenty-five
got them down two hundred and five
thousand five bedroom HMO with working
out the figures return on investment at
forty two and a half percent so a five
bedroom eight HMO being really invest
meant excellent excellent news put an
offer into the state agents afternoon
it's all been accepted convincing and
brokers will be sorted out tomorrow
hopefully you turn around within a
couple of weeks so thank you very much
Sam you for the day it's been absolutely
brilliant thank you and just tell us
briefly about the conditions the
motorway looks like condition of the
property completely empty ready to go
just needs a few carpets walls are
completely clean kitchen clean nice nice
new kitchen bathrooms bathroom and WC is
complete tidy nothing needs doing
basically compared to just a couple that
may need a bit of improvements today but
hardly anything to be spent just a few
carpets to be put on to put in and he
saw it's all sorted so good they're big
quick turnaround in a few weeks
thanks um congratulations thank you very
much Samuel and I'd recommend anybody to
come on - Samuel sir course really
knowledgeable really down-to-earth it's
great